bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est sur le
stand de sony directement au cs et sony
a présenté son tout nouveau modèle x
[Musique]
un tout nouveau smartphone que j'ai la
chance d'avoir dans les mains en tout
premier c'est un produit qui a été
annoncé hier
je suis vraiment très très content car
c'est un produit qui en termes de prise
en main est très compact entre vraiment
le design de sony
très élégant très joli c'est vrai que on
a un écran qui va vraiment d'un bord à
l'autre
quelque chose qui soit pas en une seule
caméra en façade ici une caméra au dos
se justifie le capteur d'empreintes
digitales bien positionnés en termes
d'ergonomie c'est vrai que il se tient
assez naturellement dans la main on a
assez naturellement accès en vue du
stage aux boutons sur le côté ça se
tient quand on le regarde et qu'on le
déverrouille c'est vrai que c'est un
produit qui est très élégant un écran
gorilla glass 4 5,2 pouces de diagonale
donc en termes de qualité en termes de
sécurité
normalement on est plutôt pas mal il ya
un petit côté au niveau du design un
petit côté arrondi sur les côtés qui est
très très jolie là une forme un peu
incurvé
c'est vrai que c'est sympa alors on
conserve ici un port jack
je suis très fan des par jack je suis
très content de la recharge ici je suis
possible du sbc un petit haut parleur
sur le côté
ici le lecteur de carte sim donc là on
est avec france qui bosse pour sony est
ce que en plus du trio oui enfin là est
ce que tu peux l'expliquer un peu ces
deux nouveaux modèles
oui alors avec nous aujourd'hui nous
avons un niveau expérience x2 qui est
notre téléphone un milieu de gamme avec
d'excellentes photos en fonction
en réalité cet appareil est maintenant
équipée d'une reconnaissance à prague en
ce sens en 3 giga de ram vous avez une
capacité de 32 gigas je vais monter
jusqu'à 256 yards du bluetooth 5.09 est
équipé d'un appareil photo arrière de 20
3 mégapixels et un appareil caméra
frontale de faire du slow motion
c'est vrai que sony s'est vraiment fait
remarquer avec s'est produit l'année
dernière est montée en gamme au niveau
du slow motion
là je dis pas de bêtises on va jusqu'à
120 images par seconde pour faire du
super slow mots donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt bien on peut filmer en 4k
et on a un autofocus hybride est très
très grosse panne à batterie confirme
anne modèle initial en avait retrouvé
une promis 300 milles hopper est
exactement quand les anciens modèles je
pense avait 2300 milliards pour les
riverains mais non on à 3300 pour le
nous
ok donc plus d'autonomie mais ce que le
processeur est plus gourmand aussi
peut-être je pensais pas je pense que
c'est sûr que maintenant avec la
technologie de pointe alors la
différence avec le deuxième ça c'est le
le premier salut ma rentrée alors
l'ultra qu'est ce qui est bien c'est
qu'avec cet appareil vous obtenez un
écran de 6 pouces avec double caméra
frontale extérieur d'appareils pour tout
qu'est-ce qui vous avez en avoir un
appareil photo de 5 mégapixels voilà
découvrir sous un stabilisateur d'image
optique et à l'appareil photo de 8
mégapixels
en arrière toujours là 23 l'appareil
photo de 1,3 mégapixel et la grande
nouveauté dans mon téléphone milliards
et le capteur d'empreintes digitales
pour déverrouiller le téléphone c'est
vraiment bien il est bien positionné oui
exactement
quelque chose de bien ici à savoir c'est
que l'appareil va équiper lors de la
sortie wagner avec andré euros d'amendé
chant qu'elle coule tout le pays sont
disponibles qu'en s'est produit alors
que nous n'avons pas encore de date d'un
lancement encore m ok et le privé pas
d'infos non plus n'ont pas réagi ok
merci beaucoup merci avec plaisir c'est
vraiment la présidence comme dans
optimisé pour profiter vraiment une
excellente qualité avec les casques sony
qui on puisse faire vraiment bien
d'avoir une expérience audio qui doit
vraiment être de bonne qualité
c'est un produit qui va plus loin par
rapport à son prédécesseur en termes de
prise en main en terme de qualité il me
semble vraiment bien alors pour
l'instant là j'ai pas de la formation si
on a pris directement les disponibilités
mais déguisé et les transports pourquoi
est ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
est-ce que ce sony x2
vous intéresser est ce que vous
connaissez déjà les produits de sony
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mettez moi tout ça et on en parle
ensemble on reste connectés que l'arcep
a regardé la vidéo
laissez-moi des jolis coups c'est à moi
je dis à très bientôt